you come from such a show business
family it seems like it was predestined
that you should be an actor yeah it is
the family business when you were a kid
you got cast in city slickers by billy
crystal who knew your family yeah and he
said you would just break out into song
you would do show tunes and like you'd
be in the living room doing oh you'd be
putting on full productions of cat on
the hot 10 roof or something in front of
billy crystal
and he said this kid's got it i mean the
kid is really good i mean it was like
you were one of these like theater nerds
right absolutely yeah i was a theater
nerd i was like i remember uh
when he was casting city slickers i
remember he was at some party and i i
picked up a chair as he was leaving and
i said don't forget your party favor for
some reason i remember that and he loved
that and he was like you coming on dish
you come and audition for this movie
that i'm doing and i did and then i got
the part in the movie it's almost
magical and unbelievable because uh your
parent your mother wrote did she get an
academy award or something what was
nominated yeah what did she write
running on empty running on empty which
was a big film yeah your mom's a writer
and your dad's a director
what did he direct he directed a movie
that she wrote called losing isaiah
another one called a dangerous woman and
he did a lot of television a movie
called paris trout and when you see your
parents doing that it becomes believable
that you could be a movie star or a
television actor or something it becomes
plausible right well i don't know if i
really thought about doing it
professionally when i was a kid i just
thought this was a fun thing to do like
i remember getting up on stage and i was
in
like like really young you know and just
being like this is fun you know i mean
it's fun to entertain people it's fun i
like that energy and then
yeah you know you're on a movie set when
you're a kid i don't think i registered
that you know i just registered as a kid
as my what my dad did right now it was
that was sort of his job and then over
time yeah it becomes some sort of normal
then you talk to people about oh my god
wait you're on a movie set and i go well
that's my pit my family's job it's like
our business you know see i have a
theory i don't know what your
relationship was like with your parents
but don't you think your dad's sitting
there and directing actors and look at
the attention he paid to the reverence
he had for them absolutely has to lead
you into a exactly absolutely and my dad
would always say things and encourage me
and stuff so saying like oh this is this
thing you should do you're so good at it
you should keep doing it and all that
stuff and then i'd watch him work with
actors and you're right then i'd say oh
wow like look at the attention he paid
you're right he pays attention to all
these people maybe maybe you'll pay
attention to me right imagine if i get
it
when you have a sister who's into acting
and she's older than you and so and then
you decide to go into acting
it does even she admits it does get
competitive it's kind of it would be a
lot easier if you were the only one in
the family who was into acting true or
false i don't know
i mean i get i yes but at the same time
i don't know if i would be acting if i
didn't have an older sister if i didn't
see her up on stage when i was a kid and
watch her do it i think you would be i'd
think i could do better
you cuz that's what it was maybe i mean
i kind of went like i could do that
right do you know what i mean like she
even said like you're both going up for
parts and it's like the same part
no but it is a competitive thing in
families it really is yeah i mean i
don't know i
it's it's helpful and also not helpful i
mean at a certain point you we stopped
talking about work right when we were
younger we talked a lot about work and
what we were doing and stuff and now she
has two kids and
you know i it's really about my nieces
and it's really just about
life and you know my parents got
divorced recently so it's just they're
starting their own lives separately so
it's just we're just focused more on
family now but at the same time you're
right i mean it's a competitive business
but it gets boring to be competitive
with your sibling after a while in my
opinion